what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
well my friends the game of thrones
fandom is in a bit of a frenzy after
some recent news has released regarding
jason momoa and amelia clarke i
certainly wasn't expecting to be making
a video like this but since this is what
so many fans are discussing right now i
thought i would let everyone else know
what's happening in the fandom
not long ago jason momoa released a
statement on his instagram announcing he
would be divorcing his wife lisa this
has led to a lot of speculation from the
game of thrones fans because some of
them think this might actually have
something to do with his relationship
with amelia let's have a look at one of
the many articles about this developing
news
one of the recent headlines reads
aquaman star jason mamela ends marriage
with lisa bonet fans blame game of
thrones emilia clarke jason momoa and
actress lisa bonnet have announced that
they are ending their marriage they
released a joint statement on jason's
instagram that says we have all felt the
squeeze and changes of these
transformational times a revolution is
unfolding and our family is of no
exception
feeling and growing from the seismic
shifts occurring and so we share our
family news that we are parting ways in
marriage we share this not because we
think it's newsworthy but so that as we
go about our lives we may do so with
dignity and honesty the love between us
carries on evolving in ways it wishes to
be known and lived we free each other to
be who we are learning to become our
devotion on wavering to this sacred life
and our children well as soon as this
message went viral on jason's instagram
some of his old photos with his game of
thrones star emilia clark started
surfacing online as everyone started
sharing them on social media fans are
now speculating if she was behind jason
mamoa and lisa bonay separation as you
all know jason and amelia were lovers
called drogo and daenerys targaryen in
season 1 of game of thrones now that
some of their photos are surfacing
online again fans are wondering if they
are reigniting their relationship from
game of thrones i guess the old photos
of them looking very happy has fans
wondering if amelia is the main reason
for his separation from his wife one fan
said so i guess amelia is a homewrecker
now while another fan said i knew
something felt off about this photo when
i first saw it referencing the photo of
amelia smiling while sitting on jason's
lap alright so now that you have a good
idea of what's being said about this
recent news let me give you some of my
own thoughts
honestly whatever is happening with
jason his wife lisa and maybe even
amelia clark is none of our damn
business
as far as i know jason and lisa's
separation has nothing to do with amelia
although i am only speculating like
everyone else one thing that i will say
is it is unfortunate that he is
separating from his wife from everything
that i saw over the years it did look
like they had a great relationship with
one another it does also look like jason
and amelia have a great relationship as
well but there's nothing that leads me
to believe it is anything more than just
a friendship just because they look
happy in their photos does not mean they
are seeing each other behind the scenes
why jason and his wife are divorcing is
still unknown it should remain that way
until they're ready to speak on it
because it has nothing to do with any of
us
i don't think anyone should be dragging
amelia's name through the mud when they
really don't know what happened now
you're certainly free to say whatever
you want but i would not assume anything
just because of some old photos for
jason and lisa sake i hope they find
whatever they're looking for they do
seem like great folks so i hope they end
up happy with wherever their life leads
them next
for right now leave amelia alone she's
already dealing with enough after what
happened with her character daenerys in
season 8.
[Music]
[Music]
foreign